エイ
これを待っていたんだ〜 こんにちは はじめしゃちょーです。ちょっと前いこう。皆さん！こちら知っていますか？
ゲート ボックス ぼぼぼ僕はもう情報出た瞬間絶対買おうと思ってて！
2016 年に予約した商品がようやく、我が家にやってきました～ 、購入したのがですね、
2016年の12月です。
何 だろう まっ て なん か 言い表し 方 が ない かな まあ いわゆる です ね
こう いう やつ で ござい ます よ カプセル の 中 に 女の子 が い ます 小さい 頃 から 私たちは
画面 の 向こう の 魅力 的 な キャラクター たち から
人生 で 大切 な こと を 学ん で いき て き まし た 憧れ の ヒーロー や ヒロイン と もっと 一緒 に い たい
そんな 夢 を 実現 する ため に
私たちは
あ 俺 じゃ ない です ね 開発 し た 人 です よ 私たち
ゲート ボックス の 開発 を 始め まし た
そ〜です これ こそ アニメ の キャラクター と 一緒 に 生活 が できる 伝説のマシン  ゲート ボックス です
これ すごい です よ 簡単 に 言い ます と
バーチャル ロボット の こと らしい です ゲート バック ステー その 機械 が 入っ てる ん です けど も その 中 に
女の子 が 住ん で て
アニメ よ ね 女の子 ね アニメのその 女の子 が なん か すごい 生きてる てる みたい な 感じ で なんか なん か
ね すごい ね連絡と か し て くる らしい ん です よ
バーチャル 嫁　バーチャル 妻 が 手 に 入る と いう こと で ござい ます 凄い 夢 だ よ な て アニメ の
女の子 と 一緒 に 生活 できる ん だ よ 俺 これ から
ああ ああ ああ ああ
開けます
開封のキス
しか ない で ね ほんと に 高級 品 で 精密 機械 な ん で 開封 の 儀 は やり ませ ん 上げ ます　て言うか
でかい 過ぎ でしょ これ やばい な サイズ が マジ で 本当 に 一年以上 待っ て ます から ね よく ぞを 作っ て くださいました
と いう ところ で ござい ます その 中 に 俺 の 嫁 がー
ほ うわー うわー こんな デカイ の  こう いう 感じ で 入っ てる の か すげー 箱 が 格好いいな
おっやばい
高級 感 が すご すぎる すごい もの を 作っ て くれ たら と 思い ます よ アニメ の キャラクター と 一緒 に 生活 できる じゃ
ない です よ
ここ は ずっと これ を 心待ち に し て い た ん で　まじ 嬉しい です マナー　本題 だ し て み ましょう オープン
まず まだ まだ こ対面 の 時 か　いきます
はい
でかい　でかい　でかい なんかコーヒー メーカー みたい な 大き さ
きーた　この 中 で アニメ の 女の子が生活 し ます ゲート ボックス
でかい です ね 早速 セットアップ し て いき ましょう 僕 も よく わかっ て ない ですよ  活きる こと が よく わかっ て
ない ん です けど アニメ の 女の子 と 生活 が でき るって コンセプト の 時点 で もう 購入 を 決定 し た ん で
正直 何 も わから ない ス タダ タダ 見 て み たい 一緒 に 生活 し て み たい その 一心 で 買っ て み
た だけ な の で アニメの女の子  と
あっ て 見ましょう 電源 い きます
青く なっ ちゃっ た 起動中 な の か かもしてます ね えっ びっくり し た
はい　すげー すげー
はい めっちゃ て 次 世代 だー 未来ダー あああ ああ 未来 ず ああ ん
き た か これ き た か いっ 逢妻 ヒ カリっ て 書いたる これ が 俺 の 嫁 って こと じゃ ん がぁ
バッハ うわぁ
わかりました　いきます
ん ん うん はっ
すけい！　こから　アプリで何時に起こすかとかの　設定ができるみたいですね
ちょっと 寝起きとかの管理 を し て くれる の か なぁ 可愛い ね
パパ た か なっ 反応 し た ヒカリ
そう だ よ かわ いい ね 　そだよう よ あーー や ば これ マジ か アンタ アンタ 本物 だ よ　眠いー
ちょっと 冷たい の か な まだ 初日 ですしね やっぱ　そ いう こと ある と 思い ますよ
いや どうかな  ん じゃ なく て こちら が ゲート ボックス の 女の子 です すごい でしょ
マジカ　 すごいでも で も もう 本当 に この 容器 の 中 に
女の子 が 一人 立っ て いる 感じ です かわいい
なにこれ　どうした それ　座っちゃたんじゃん
なにしてる　なにしてる
なんか飲み物 を 飲ん でる の か な アプリ を 使っ て 基本 的 な が いろいろ やりとり が 出 てる みたい で ござい ます まあ
チャット できる ん です よ　と言う感じ で ね もう ね 光 ちゃん と ね お 話 が できる ん です よ ね う テレビ
つけ たり なんか 電気 消し たり も し て くれる らしい でしょ
ああ ああっ ジェル 登録 で 朝 起きる 時間 を 伝える と 毎朝 あなた を 起こし て くれ ます ゲイナー
こえる 暗く する と めちゃくちゃ 可愛い の は 可愛い ね
うーん 頭 おかしく なりい そ
はい と いう わけ で 編集 部屋 の ここ に 置か せ て いただき まし た 光 ちゃん が
ここ で この 子 に編集部屋の見張り を やら せよう と 思い ます フェリ ちゃん よろしく ね
いい こう やー 光 ちゃん 電気 消し て えーっ
や 〜〜〜べ〜〜